how do you deal with jealous co-workers
if you have a full-time job if you're
working somewhere and you have a dream
to start your own thing you're going to
find that the people you're working with
often will be jealous of what you're
doing because they want to do the same
thing but they don't have the guts to go
out and do it some people will be
supportive and others will just be
flat-out jealous you can't let their
jealousy their hatred their negativity
towards you hold you back from making
something great their opinions are
irrelevant I've got a great question
from one of our readers Cornell who
wrote in with that problems there's a
full-time job starting a filmmaking
business and all of the coworkers are
really jealous of what's going on
and the question is how do I handle this
how do I handle the ignorance and the
awkward jokes and the jealousy that come
from my co-workers so I want to share
with you a couple of coping mechanisms
that can help and and what helped me
when I was starting my business one
nugget of wisdom that will share with me
a long time ago by by a friend when
dealing with people who you're having an
argument with is try to imagine like
they're a baby or really really old
person because we tend to have more
patience right if there's if there's a
baby who's yelling at you or
three-year-olds was yelling at you who
doesn't understand the difference
necessarily between right or wrong you
have a little bit more patience so
somebody's coming at you with a lot of
negativity try to just imagine them as
being an ignorant three-year-old
and have a little more patience so
that's first the second you can decide
not to share right I mean it's great
that you are starting your business
while you're still at your job right
it's a great way to start a business
make sure that you're going to earn an
income from it and then move off and
eventually become full-time on your own
but in the meantime if people are hating
around you then just don't share don't
share what's going on in your business
with them don't share all the big wins
that you're having because it's only
going to cause more negativity the third
option is if you're going to share don't
just share the good stuff show them the
pain
show them the vulnerability show them
that you're scared children that you
have no idea what you're doing
show them that you're in way over
head nobody wants to beat up on somebody
to win they're down right there jealous
of you and they're there throwing
punches at you because they think you're
off to a better place and they're
jealous right they want to go with you
they want to do that for themselves but
they're not able to do it they don't
have the guts to do it shatter the
illusion that this is a perfect world
that this is so easy and you're making
tons of money like this is really hard
and you're scared and if you share that
with them it's really hard to get on
somebody and make fun of them if they're
sharing that they're really scared about
something but if you come in and you're
acting all tough and and you just landed
this big deal and you're bragging about
it then of course people are going to
hate on you and they're going to be
really jealous
I'll make jokes but if you're being
really vulnerable and really real then
it breaks down the walls a little bit
and they won't be as quick to criticize
you okay the last option here is to just
ignore them you know what you're doing
your thing you're building your dream
you're doing the right thing you're
passionate what you're doing you're
helping people you know you're not going
to be there for very long at that job
you're going to have your own company
doing great things ignore the haters
because you're going to have them always
in your business if it's not the
full-time people who are you're working
with it's going to be other people
around you there's always going to be
people who are jealous of what you're
doing it has nothing to do with you with
their own insecurities and you can lap
them off and ignore them because you
know you're doing the right thing one
thing that really helped me when I was
getting my business started I was in
University and I had a really tough
decision as to whether I should start my
own business I was running there already
part-time I didn't know if I should jump
into that full-time or if I should go
get a job and I had interviewed with
some really successful companies and
thought maybe I should go work for them
I wasn't entirely sure what to do with
my career and all of my friends were
going that route they were all getting
jobs and so that's really it's really
hard to go the other way you know when
your friends are all doing one thing and
you're the only black sheep it's really
hard to have the courage in Fortitude to
go a different direction and so what I
did was
some friends were really encouraging and
some friends were jealous and thought it
was stupid for doing my own thing
instead of taking a high paying job it's
really important that you create an
environment for yourself
that builds you up that lifts you up and
that's from the friends that you hang
out with that's when the family members
who are around you that's from the books
you read the websites you visit the
things that you listen to and the people
and the information that do not support
you you illuminate for your life you
know if you have friends that just keep
hating on you and saying what a bad idea
this is maybe they shouldn't be your
friends anymore right what kind of
friend does that now you may not have a
whole lot of options right now these are
your co-workers and hopefully eventually
are going to move and become your own
boss and not have to deal with people
who you don't want to deal with but at
the same time build up a network around
you of people who do believe in what
you're doing talk to other people who
have started filmmaking companies hang
around those guys read biographies of
people like George Lucas and Steven
Spielberg and how they got started and
let their wisdom help guide you because
it can be hard if you're by yourself and
you have people just hating on you and
seeing what a bad idea it is and making
jokes and you're by yourself it takes a
lot of guts to keep going I don't know
if I could have done it what helped me
through was reading those famous
entrepreneur stores and real isn't that
those guys struggled and that there is
something and I'm building this for the
right reason and it just gave me more
confidence to keep going to keep going
one more day one more day one more day
and seeing that they struggled in the
early years made me feel like I could
make it to if they could make it I could
make it so those are a few strategies to
help you deal with with the co-workers
and also really encourage you to build
that supportive network around you
because that can make all the difference
in you deciding whether to go for it or
not or whether to continue or not and
and if you really believe in this if you
think you can make a difference as an
entrepreneur I want to see that you have
the opportunity to go and do it believe
those are you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up
I'd also love to hear we have to think
please leave a comment under the video I
will answer each one I promise I'll make
a video reply for those where it's
warranted thank you so much I'll see you
soon